i'd like to thank
secretary general stoltenberg for
hosting this nato defense ministerial
it certainly comes an important time for
the alliance
as russia continues building up their
military presence
along ukraine's borders
including in crimea
in belarus and in the black sea
in many ways
this brings russian troops
right up to nato's doorstep
so let me begin today by making clear
that
amer america's commitment to nato into
article 5
remains ironclad
as president biden said a couple of days
ago
we will if we must
defend every inch
of nato territory
there's no reason of course that it
should come it should ever come to this
just like there's no reason for russia
to again invade ukraine
ukraine does not threaten anyone
let alone its russian neighbors
and yet that is what moscow would have
us believe
and that is how mr putin continues to
justify
his assembly of significant combat power
now the russians say that they are
withdrawing some of those forces now
that exercises are complete
but we don't see that
quite the contrary we see them add to
the more than 150 000 troops that they
already have
arrayed along that border
even in the last couple of days
we see some of those troops inch closer
to that border
we see them fly in more combat and
support aircraft
we see them sharpen their readiness in
the black sea
we even see them
stocking up their blood supply supplies
you know i was a soldier myself not that
long ago
and i know firsthand that you don't do
these sort of things
for no reason
and you certainly don't do them if
you're getting ready to pack up and go
home
so we and our allies will stay vigilant
we will watch for the so-called false
flag operations
where russia manufactures a dramatic
event to justify an attack
a play that we've seen them run in the
past
and we will continue to explore ways to
enhance our readiness
as united states and others have done
with additional troop deployments
to nato's eastern flank
and we will
we will closely match
russian words to russian deeds
what they say
to what they actually do
of course one thing that mr putin says
he wants to do is to engage in more
dialogue
and as we have said all along we would
welcome that
we believe there's still time and space
for diplomacy to work
and we are in lockstep with our allies
and partners towards that end
a peaceful outcome
that respects ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
represents the best outcome
for ukraine to be sure but also for
russia and the russian people
if mr mr putin is serious about
achieving that sort of outcome
he will find in the united states and in
this alliance
no better or more serious interlocutor
and if he's not
as his deeds thus far tend to indicate
it will be clear to the entire world
that he started a war
with diplomatic options left on the
table
it will be mr putin who will bear the
responsibility
for the suffering and the immense
sacrifice
that ensues
you know i've been doing this for a long
time
this business of national security
i joined the united states army in the
middle of the cold war
and i have served and fought alongside
nato allies for the better part of my
adult life
but i can honestly say that
i have never seen the alliance
more relevant
and more united
and more resolute than i see it today
mr putin says that he doesn't want a
strong nato on his western flight
he's getting exactly that
i'll soon depart for poland and then to
lithuania to spend some time
with these strong allies who likewise
take these obligations seriously
i'll visit with their troops
and mine
see their leaders
talk with mine and talk about how
together we can bolster
the defense of the alliance
i'd also like to add my appreciation to
bulgaria
who just today agreed to host a u.s army
striker company
for joint training opportunities
these troops will be departing germany
in the coming days and they'll help
ensure
our readiness and our interoperability
with bulgaria
as our nato ally
all that is to say that i leave here
incredibly proud
of the alliance
and satisfied in the knowledge that we
will be sure footed
in the face of aggression
but dedicated
as always to the prospect of peace
harry truman the american president when
nato was found
are founded
but at best when he noted that
though peace was difficult
war was not inevitable
and so
it is today
there is nothing inevitable
about this looming conflict
it can still be averted
the pl the path of diplomacy may be
difficult
but it is still worth the trek
and nato as i said
remains sure-footed
thank you